foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
on the 24th of February 2022 the
European Parliament and the EU
immediately condemned the aggression
Europe took action to support Ukraine
um
as Russia's aggression grew Bolder and
the destruction increased Parliament
backed round after round of economic
sanctions on Putin and his enablers
millions of people fled the rockets and
shells Europeans opened their doors and
the EU granted refugees unprecedented
protection
foreign
[Music]
as Russia plunged Ukraine into darkness
by attacking power supplies and civilian
infrastructure
as winter began to bite Parliament sent
generators of Hope
yep
when Russia committed war crimes
Parliament declared its a state sponsor
of terrorism
when Ukraine's economy buckled
parliament-backed suspending import
duties and voted for 18 billion euros of
support for Ukraine in 2023
as ukrainians fought for their freedom
and democracy parliaments called for
more weapons and assistance for the
country's military
when Russia tried to isolate Ukraine
parliament-backed granting it EU
candidate status Paving the way to join
the European Union
Ukraine's future is in the European
Union slavo crane
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we were with you then
we are with you now we will be with you
for as long as it takes
[Music]